bonjour l'homme il a toujours eu un
rapport très spécial autant des fois il
passe trop lentement des fois il passe
trop rapidement
et pourtant c'est lui qui régit
l'univers grâce à lui on a le mouvement
c'est ce phénomène physique qui permet
aux particules d'interagir les unes avec
les autres
des fois de manière simple et
compréhensible
telle une pomme qui tombe d'un arbre et
des fois de façon totalement mystérieuse
et magique comme l'amour qui peut se
créer entre deux personnes ces
interactions ils surviennent de façon
inattendue
mais une chose est sûre c'est que
lorsqu'elles ont eu lieu elles ont eu
lieu et rien qu'on puisse faire ne peut
changer cela alors à défaut de vouloir
maîtriser
c'est mon futur l'homme s'est attardé à
vouloir maîtriser les moments passés
c'est à dire les graver dans les
mémoires que ce soit à travers les
gravures préhistoriques ou via les
photos et vidéos de nos smartphones
d'aujourd'hui l'homme il a toujours
voulu matérialiser une certaine façon
nous souvenir comme si le souvenir en
lui-même ne suffisait pas alors le monde
bouge très vite on a arrivé aujourd'hui
dans des mondes rempli paradoxe de plus
en plus est ce que vous êtes déjà
retrouvé dans une situation pareille ou
au lieu de profiter du moment présent
vous étiez derrière votre caméra
c'est exactement cette problématique
qu'on a voulu relever avec la première
start-up que j'ai cofondé s'appelait
smart zeroes smart les acronymes de
systèmes machine à remonter le temps
notre ambition était de développer des
produits des objets connectés pour
capturer ce qu'on vivait au moment même
et ce après l'avoir vécu donc notre
premier produit se focaliser sur le sens
auditif donc grâce à des bijoux
connectés qu'on placé au niveau des
oreilles on peut capturer le son en
quatre dimensions dans quatre dimensions
il ya deux fonctionnalités celle de la
3d qui permet de capturer le son dans sa
spécialité
si bien que derrière lorsqu on réécoute
avec des écouteurs on est totalement
immergé la même façon dont on l'a vécu
au à l'origine la deuxième fois
été c'est la quatrième dimension vous
l'aurez deviné c'est celle du temps
c'est une fonctionnalité qui permettait
de capturer avec cette immersion de 3d
quelque chose qui était déjà passé alors
la prouesse technique est relativement
simple
en fait on avait une mémoire tampon qui
enregistrait en continu tout ce qui se
passait en trois dimensions et lorsqu on
vivait un de ces moments qu'on n'avait
pas trop quelle on s'attendait pas et
pas on appuie sur un bouton par défaut
les 42 dernières secondes son prix de
cette mémoire tampon et stockées en
mémoire dure plus on appuie longtemps
plus remonter dans le temps et on
stockait ce qui s'était passé
si on n'avait pas eu la chance de vivre
quelque chose d'extraordinaire eh ben on
faisait rien et le souvenir s'effacer au
fur et à mesure alors l'idée avait
énormément pull encore aujourd'hui on
n'a pas une seule personne qui nous ont
qui nous a dit que c'était une idée bête
alors tout a commencé le 7 janvier 2015
où j'ai rencontré celui qui allait être
mon futur associé sachiez cette idée
nous a valu le premier prix de la cité
de l'objet connecter un concours qu'ils
avaient organisée pour l'heure une
inauguration donc en juin 2015
on a eu l'opportunité de rencontrer des
grands acteurs de la france telle que
emmanuel macron françois hollande et à
partir de là ça a été l'effet boule de
neige mais littéralement c'est à dire
que on a eu la chance de passer devant
dans des grandes chaînes de télévision
dans la presse locale et nationale
même internationale et à la radio
également
alors je vous avoue qu'on a bien profité
de ces six mois ça a duré six mois on
était des robes star on était invitée
partout se ranger en mode vip et j'avoue
que c'était très plaisant
la petite cerise sur le gâteau c'était
lorsqu'on a été invité tous frais payés
au cms de las vegas en 2016 et on était
sans doute la start up la plus jeune de
l'histoire du cs a exposé là bas alors
faut pas penser que le monde à la start
up tout est rose
il ya des moments plus compliqués on a
dû travailler on a dû travailler très
dur des fois les journées de 10 heures
12 heures voire 14 heures alors moi qui
avait une peur bleue de travail et je me
suis rendu compte que oui j'étais
capable de travailler
selon un projet qui me passionnait alors
on avait des objectifs on savait où
aller par contre étant donné que c'était
notre premier projet entrepreneurial
je ne savais pas par où passait par quel
chemin prendre
c'est ce qui nous a valu des grosses
remises en question on a touché le fond
plus d'une fois on saignements risque
ont continué ce qu'on continue pas avec
star et malheureusement pour moi ça a
été la fin ça c'est une grosse remise en
question qui m'a valu mon départ de
l'entreprise
et j'avoue que ça a été très dur pendant
six mois je me suis remis huit ans en
question est-ce que je reste est ce que
je pars j'avais donné beaucoup de mon
temps de l'énergie aussi je m'étais
attaché au projet comme si c'était mon
propre bébé et ce jeu remet dans le
contexte s'il ya 90% de start up qui
échoue et voici les raisons les vingt
principales raisons j'aimerais qu'on
s'attarde sur les trois principales
celles qui nous ont celle qui nous a
touchés visiblement elles ne
disparaissent pas mais voilà il ya le
besoin du marché
on avait payé cher une étude de marché
pour essayer de valider l'idée tout le
monde faisait à l'idée géniale c'est
super ok très bien
est-ce que vous l'achetez et là c'était
une des premières grosses claques qu'on
s'est prise et bien les gens ne
voulaient pas avoir des souvenirs que
audio même aussi immersive qui soit par
contre on a eu la chance de mettre le
doigt sur un marché qu'on n'avait pas du
tout identifier s'était soldée
malvoyants il paraît que il semblerait
qu'ils aient pas besoin de visuels donc
pour nous c'était le réflexe ultime pour
eux donc là on avait l'opportunité de
pivoter dans le jargon de start-up
pivoter c'est changer sensiblement ou
totalement le produit pour s'attaquer à
un nouveau marché et c'est là où nos
visions respectifs ont divergé avec mon
ex associé il ya une quatrième raison
qui n'est pas répertorié c'est celle que
j'ai rajouté sait faire la part des
choses entre la passion et la raison ça
vous est sans doute arrivée vous lancer
dans un projet corps et âme et au fur et
à mesure et bien il ya des oeillères
kiki qui se créent et vous avez
absolument vie que votre projet
réussisse
mais à cause de ses oeillères vous êtes
incapable de prendre la distance et
prendre des décisions rationnelles pour
le bien du projet donc c'est l'ensemble
de ces quatre raisons c'est ce qui a
justifié mon départ douloureux de
l'entreprise alors en france l'échec est
vue de deux manières c'est un peu
binaire soit on prend un côté ont réussi
soit on prend l'autre côté on échoue
c'est comme ça qu'on nous apprend dès
l'école soit à la moyenne tu passes ta
pas la moyenne du redouble et on te voit
qu'un absolue de rots et qui aujourd'hui
est fier d'avoir redoublé et pourtant
ici vous si vous prenez la direction de
l'échec
eh ben vous a gagné le jackpot en on
catégorise comme un raté et souvent
notre crédibilité est remise en question
pour les projets pour les prochains
projets alors ça c'est propre à la
france comme je vous ai dit c'est comme
ça qu'on voit en france et la plupart
des personnes qui ont réussi
ils savent que c'est pas comme ça qu au
final il ya un seul chemin qui mène vers
la victoire
il y en a juste quelques uns qui vont
encore plus d'obstacles que d'autres le
seul vrai échec dans la vie c'est celui
de ne pas essayer et j'aimerais partager
avec vous une citation de nelson mandela
qui disait je ne perds jamais soit je
gagne soit j'apprends et c'est vraiment
la philosophie de l'entrepreneur
aujourd'hui pour réussir
alors voici tout ce que j'ai appris j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses j'aimerais
partager maintenant avec vous ce que
j'ai pu apprendre avec 10 points clés si
jamais il y en a quelques-uns d'entre
vous qui aimerait un jour entreprendre
en mode start up ce que j'appelle start
up je définis rapidement parce que sur
les médias vous avez deux définitions
start up qui est un peu popularisé qui
est une entreprise qui commence
simplement c'est pas celle que j'aime et
c'est pas celle qui est utilisée dans la
silicon valley la silicon valley la
start-up ses jeunes pousses innovantes
qui a un groupe fort potentiel de
croissance et qui fait souvent sujet de
levée de fonds
alors lorsque vous allez vous lancer
vous allez vous poser des questions
alors par où commencer comment est ce
que je vais me prendre
bon bien faire avec kim associés et
éventuellement ou est-ce que je peux
trouver de l'argent
toutes ces questions sont légitimes tout
entrepreneur se les poser au départ et
il faut pas avoir honte de se les poser
surtout de chercher les réponses
alors voici si vous avez commencé par
l'idée évidemment faut commencer par
quelques pas et où comme vous avez vus à
travers mon expérience l'idée a elle
même ne suffit pas il faut la confronter
au marché donc faire une étude de marché
qui viendra valider oui ou non la
solution que vous proposez une fois
qu'elle est validée vous allez vous
entourer d'un premier d'une première
équipe qui ne sera pas celle qui va
constituer l'entreprise après mais c'est
une première équipe qui va vous aider à
produire ce qu'on appelle le mvp
alors hop j'avance un bon mvp c'est ce
qu'on appelle le minimum valdes ball
claude acte c'est le prototype que vous
allez pouvoir présenter à vos
consommateurs potentiels pour qu'ils
aient une idée fiable de la solution que
vous proposez aux problèmes posés
alors pour avoir un bon ldp faut
absolument qu'il ait un petit peu de
chaque critère donc la fonctionnalité
l'usabilité l'aspect design également si
vous développez seulement à fond un seul
des critères et là votre client
potentiel ne peut pas extrapoler avec le
produit final
à partir de ce mvp vous allez refaire
une étude de marché pour valider cette
fois la solution
le produit c'est pas parce que l'idée
les gens ils ont accès c'est l'idée que
la solution vous apporter sous forme de
produit est correct et donc là vous
allez validé produit une fois que ça
c'est fait vous allez pouvoir entrer
dans le dur du gier et là avec un modèle
kamba on va pas aller dans le détail ne
lisez pas ce qui est en jaune parce que
c'est invivable
mais ça c'est absolument primordial de
passer par là c'est ce qui va permettre
de mettre en avant les acteurs et les
parties prenantes dans le mode projet
comment est ce que je vais
commercialiser mon produit par quel
biais je vais attendre mes clients qui
sont mes clients déjà quels sont les
partenaires clés et c'est à partir de ce
business model
vous allez former du coup votre équipe
la team celle qui va constituer du coup
la rédaction de des statuts du pacte
d'associés du coup création de
l'entreprise
et là il est important très important de
bien définir le rôle de chacun c'était
une erreur qu'on a fait on était tous
les deux ingénieurs et c'est important
de bien distinguer le rôle de chacun
pour éviter les conflits ça c'est à moi
de le faire non c'est moi qui vais le
faire voilà chacun son rôle dans
l'entreprise et sa faut le mettre dans
le pacte d'associés
à partir de là vous aurez fait en
parallèle ce qu'on appelle un business
plan
en fait c'est le document clé que vous
allez présenter aux investisseurs
c'est un amas de réponses à toutes les
questions qu'on peut poser sur votre
projet alors il y aura tout ce que vous
avez vu avant l'étude de marché la
concurrence
votre équipe qu'est ce que vous avez
comme ressources en interne et que ça la
trésorerie pré ventes prévisionnelles
ce document il est primordial pourquoi
pour aller chercher les investisseurs et
ici je vais vous donner comment est ce
que je peux partir de rien et créer une
entreprise parce que la plupart ici sont
des étudiants et même ceux qui ne sont
pas étudiants c'est un jour il veut se
lancer comment est ce que je trouve de
l'argent parce que vous avez le choix
entre soit travail en tant qu'ingénieur
ou en tant que voilà salariés et gagnez
votre route
ou bien vous décidé de lancer en tant
qu'entrepreneur ya hélas vous avez le
problème de l'argent qui se pose
indéniablement et vous avez la chose la
chance d'être en france qui est un pays
où il fait sans doute le mieux pour
monter une boîte alors je vais vous
accompagnez ici la première étape ça va
être pôle emploi et la caf
si vous avez cotisé nous allons à vos
allocations chômage voulaient toucherait
jusqu'à un moment où vous pourrez vous
tourner vers la caf où vous avez droit
au rsa et les allocations logement
petite anecdote 1 j'ai touché le rsa
pendant deux ans ça m'a permis de vivre
très convenablement dans la ville où il
fait le mieux vivre en france s'est
hissée ranger voilà alors vous avez créé
l'entreprise
vous allez vouloir mettre un apport
initial ce qu'on appelle le capital de
départ
si vous avez de l'argent de côté tant
mieux vous le mettez si vous en avez pas
vous avez vous tourné vers la love
la love money c'est l'argent du coeur
c'est ceux de vos proches votre
grand-mère qui vous donne mille cinq
cents euros pour vous aider dans votre
projet les parents qui sont là pour vous
aider un ami qui donne 10 euros le de 50
tout ça mis bout à bout vous allez
vouloir faire un capital de départ
la somme que je préconise c'est trente
mille euros parce que les aides que vous
avez notamment ici avec la bpi la banque
populaire banque publique
d'investissement sacré à pour ce french
tech qui permet de subvenir à une bourse
qui à la hauteur de votre capital
donc si vous avez dit il ils ont dit non
dit neil donc autant rentabiliser
et à voir les 30000 avec ça vous avez
les prêts d'honneur ce sont des prêts à
l'entrepreneur des prêts à taux zéro
pour rembourser au fur et à mesure des
années qui passent
donc vous ne remboursez que ce que vous
avez emprunté il en existe deux
différents à ça et coupler un prêt
bancaire à tous très préférentiels ou
vous êtes encore à hauteur du capital
donc en fête avec ses trois étapes là si
vous avez 30 euros trente mille euros au
capital
vous pouvez vous en sortir avec 150000
euros sans dilution de l'entreprise
c'est-à-dire que vous et vous associez
rester 100% mètres de l'entreprise
je vais vous mettre le reste du tableau
mais on va pas aller dans le détail
c'est juste pour montrer tout ce qui
existe en france comme dispositifs
publics et privés pour croître très vite
au niveau de votre start up
juste un petit clin d'oeil en bas à
droite
il y a le critère d'innovation il faut
absolument que cette start up etc je
reviens aux définitions qu'elle soit
innovante c'est à dire qu elle un
caractère nouveau par rapport à ce qui
existe sur le marché déjà pour avoir le
droit à toutes ces subventions
alors je vais finir mon stock par une
question qu'on pose souvent c'est
pourquoi est ce que j'ai voulu devenir
entrepreneur quand j'ai arrêté mes
études
eh ben j'ai fait une année sabbatique ou
chalets à droite à gauche et travaillent
en temps chez mcdo en tant que serveur
chez des traiteurs je voulais absolument
de déconnecter de du monde de
l'ingénierie et c'était vraiment pas pur
hasard que j'ai rencontré mon futur à
zurich pour proposer ça et je les fais
et aujourd'hui j'ai essayé de chercher
les raisons sur internet pourquoi les
entrepreneurs préfèrent entrepreneurs
avec le salariat je vois mes potes qui
gagnent beaucoup
j'encaisse très bien ils ont beau à part
des belles voitures
sauf que moi je ressens pas le besoin de
tout ça parce qu'il va manquer deux
choses de ressource inestimable que
l'argent ne pourrait jamais acheter
c'est le temps et la liberté
merci
[Applaudissements]